[Music]
hey outlander fans leanna giller with
entertainment tonight here joined by the
amazing sam hewitt thank you very much
of course and we are in the outlander
armory it's one of my favorite places uh
it's actually one of the coldest places
possibly on the planet and i understand
you're gonna give me a little bit of a
tour i'm gonna give you a tour of uh
some of the weaponry that we use not
only in season one and two but also
season three awesome let's take a look
uh the beginning of this season we start
with culloden in which we've been uh
trying to to stop
um fate has got us to this point and in
the battle traditionally the highlanders
would have used this basket hilt
a sword this is actually mine you can uh
have a go of that that's a shark skin
wow the grip there uh and also of course
the dirk which is you see jamie carrying
this a lot it's also very sharp and
these would have been uh the highlanders
traditional
weapons against the brown bess musket
that is heavy uh very heavy yes yes uh
whole army you know very modern army it
is very heavy oh gosh yeah but uh you
know they had to go up against like you
know hundreds thousands of men with
these and it was um really a one-way
battle that's not a spoiler at all so
for your sword have you become familiar
with this are you comfortable with this
now i'm very comfortable with my sword
thank you yes i do sleep
with it under my pillow it's uh it's one
of my favorite parts i love the the
basket on it um but actually jamie is um
this is a lot of different weapons this
season and at one point i do get to use
a bow and arrow i was gonna say talk to
me about this because we haven't seen
jamie with a bow and arrow before we got
a great uh bowmaster to come in and
teach us how to use it we even have a
straw wicker man
made for target practice maybe we could
uh interview him later you should have a
go you should have a go oh okay right at
least just like give us the basics as to
how you would hold it um
it's this this way up
you point the pointy thing
at uh the bad people oh um that is a
real one
uh so i'll use the fake one in case i
kill your camera man this one
always have this bit pointed towards you
and uh and there you go you sort of pull
it up and the last second you just um
release it's it's a great fun everyone
should have a go
start running now and i'll uh i'll give
you i'll give you a couple of seconds
head start
it's great that you guys have so many
different weapons here have you had any
mishaps over the past three seasons
no not really uh not with any of the
weaponry at all i actually did backfist
uh tobias menzies recently which was
kind of good fun
so i think that might make the blooper
reel was that while he was actually
using this sword
oh wow this is uh blackjack randall's
um sabre traditionally used for on top
of horseback we were having a fight and
uh i did a spinning back fist one of my
signature moves and oh you have a
signature and actually uh yeah smacked
him in the face
that's pretty good
so how does this sword fare against this
one
let's find out shall we all right what
would you like to learn i would like to
learn the basic
maybe we should have a plastic one
do we have plastic ones i won't stab you
okay cool
like no one's gonna stop me i were to
come at you like this i would probably
do this do my signature spinning back
fist and hit you in the face okay great
we'll leave it up there yeah good place
to leave it good place before anyone
gets hurt that might happen in here it's
very lucky
well sam thank you so much for showing
me around the outlander
you're very welcome anytime now leave
all of you
[Music]
you